-Our next guest can be seen
this weekend
at the New York Comedy Cellar.
Making his "Tonight Show" debut,
please welcome the very funny
Sean Donnelly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes!
Yes!
We're doing it!
How are you?
It's so good to be here.
I had so many milestones
this year.
I turned 43, everybody.
43 years old.
[ Audience cheers ]
Yeah.
I look 55, but I turned 43.
It sucks.
I even live in Queens now.
Queens, New York --
that's where I live.
[ Audience cheers ]
Yeah.
I used to live in Brooklyn,
but then I turned 40,
and they kick you out
of Brooklyn when you turn 40.
"Time Out" and "New York"
magazine,
they come to your house
and they kick you out.
It's actually just a hipster
with a giant scarf on a scooter.
He just scoots to your house,
and he just rings the bell.
He goes, "You gotta go!"
I'm like, "I gotta go,
I gotta get out of here."
[ Laughs ]
I'm getting used to being older.
My body is changing.
I used to do acid.
Now I have acid reflux.
[ Laughter ]
I also learned about ear hair.
I don't know if you guys
have that.
Ear hair is a thing
in your 40s.
Nobody told me I would become
a monster at 43.
The only cool thing about
ear hair is that if you're alone
and you start to play with it
and you're bored,
it sounds like you have
a tiny deejay inside your head.
So you're like --
[ Imitating record scratch ]
You're old!
You don't have a 401(k).
What, wha-what,
wha-wha-wha-what,
Your prostate is broken.
What, what,
wha-wha-wha-what.
[ Applause ]
I had another milestone
this year.
I lost 60 pounds, everybody.
60 pounds.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Yeah.
Some of you are clapping
and some of are you like,
"No, you didn't,"
and that's messed up.
I did it
with intermittent fasting.
'Cause I was trying everything.
I even went to a trainer
at the gym.
And after one of the workouts,
I go,
"That was a really hard
workout."
And he goes,
"That was the stretching.
I hate to break it to you.
And you're in
a Dick's Sporting Goods.
I didn't really want to
tell you that one."
And I was like,
"Yeah, but I used
your stair machine."
He's like, "That's an escalator.
Do you not know that?
That's crazy."
[ Chuckles ]
I tried dating a bunch
this year.
I went on two Zoom dates,
everybody.
[ Audience cheers ]
Yeah.
It didn't work out.
There was a bad connection.
Thank you so much.
[ Audience laughs, groans ]
Yes, it was a dad joke,
but I look like a dad,
so shut up!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I went on a date
with a girl from Bumble.
And after the date, I knew
we wouldn't meet up again,
but I wanted
to be nice about it.
So I wrote her a message.
I said, "Hey, thanks so much
for meeting up."
You know, "Have a good one."
And she wrote back,
"Yes, very enjoyable
meeting you, as well.
Good luck
on all your future endeavors."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Did I
just get fired from a date?"
[ Laughter ]
What, does Bumble
have an HR department?
'Cause I still want to do,
like, normal life.
I want to have kids.
But I'm over 40.
And if you're over 40
and you don't have kids,
you just become
the weird guy around kids.
Like, if I met your kids,
I'd be like, "Hello!"
[ Laughter ]
I'd be like, "How are you?"
Like, not in a messed up way.
I just like kids.
And the other day,
I walked out of a store,
and I see these parents
with their toddler.
And the toddler is, like,
screaming his head off,
crying, right.
So I think I'm going to help.
And I go, "What's the matter?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, thinking he'll turn
around and go, "I'm a toddler.
I'm tired.
Don't worry about it."
But he doesn't.
He turns around,
and he goes like this.
Like, "Pick me up"
kind of thing.
So now I'm like, "Do I pick up
this strange baby?"
In the middle of New York City?
And I look at the dad for, like,
permission to hug the baby.
I go, "Can I hug your baby?"
He's like, "Yeah, I guess.
I don't know. Go ahead."
[ Laughter ]
Which is such a dad response.
If it was a mom, she'd be like,
"I need three forms of I.D.
and a phone bill
before you look at my kid."
A dad is like, "I don't
even know if it's my kid."
[ Laughter ]
So this is totally true.
So I did, I picked up the baby.
And I ran as fast as I could.
I ran and I ran and I ran.
And now I'm raising a baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's actually not true.
The real ending of that story
is I picked up the baby
and we both looked at each other
like we shouldn't be doing this,
and I put the baby down.
Thank you so much, everybody.
I'm Sean Donnelly.
Good night. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[Speaks indistinctly]
their head on a scooter.
-[ Laughs ]
-Sean Donnelly!
He'll be at the New York
Comedy Cellar this weekend.